a hole in a plane government
investigations aircraft being grounded
12 billion wiped from the stock price
and Airlines re-examining their aircraft
to find yet more manufacturing faults
this wasn't exactly the start to 2024
that Boeing wanted see after spending
years enduring The Fallout from the max
crisis where two Boeing planes crashed
due to a flight control design floor
killing hundreds of people the company
was finally showing signs of a full
recovery they had normalized production
levels they were getting some more
respect down Wall Street but then a door
plug from an Alaska Airlines Boeing
aircraft which had only been delivered
months before fell off in midair
triggering yet another crisis for the
company what does Boeing look like in
the next few years if it has to deal
with another crisis so can Boeing afford
another
setback while nobody was killed or
seriously injured in the Alaska Airlines
accident we could have ended up with
something so much more tragic and really
fortunate that that did not occur here
the door plug which is a panel used to
plug up the space where an emergency
exit would be fell off early in the
flight it was shortly after takeoff
passengers were still in their seat belt
the plane was ascending and there was no
one seated right next to the to the door
plug that blew off if somebody had been
in that seat it's likely they probably
would have died that's at least what
we're told by the NTSB and that's really
what's triggered this massive panic and
investigation into what actually
happened one major question in the
accident investigator's probe is whether
this was a one-off accident with a
singular door plug or a manufacturing
issue that could affect many of Boeing's
aircraft the door plugs are manufactured
by a company called Spirit Aeros systems
which actually used to be part of Boeing
until the division was spun off in 2005
Spirit has said it's working with boing
to determine what went wrong but a
crucial piece of evidence the bolts that
are supposed to hold the door plug in
place remain missing and we have not yet
determined if they exist existed there
figuring out what happened with the
bolts is a key piece of this the
accident led to the FAA grounding around
170 max9 aircraft and ordering the
inspection of the planes but it wasn't
long before the reputational damage to
Boeing and the FAA began to spread
further than the max 9's door plugs see
when it comes to recommendations
inspections and safety checks for Boeing
and other americanmade aircraft Airlines
and Regulators across the globe
typically follow the lead of the FAA
however around the same time that both
United Airlines and Alaska Airlines
announced they'd found loose bolts on
their aircraft what we saw was Airlines
saying you know what we're going to
check our aircraft our Boeing Max
aircraft even though they're not the
models that the FAA has stipulated need
to be checked despite having no Max 9
aircraft South Korea China and India all
ordered their Airlines to examine their
Fleet of Max 8 aircraft though they
found nothing and Indonesia ordered lion
a to inspect the door doors on its Max 9
aircraft it's certainly a sign that uh
Boeing doesn't have full full confidence
of safety Regulators or its Airline
customers that really speaks to this
idea that there may be a loss of faith
not just in Boeing but also in Boeing's
oversight by the FAA the faa's
administrator Mike Whitaker said the
agency showed its Global Leadership on
safety by immediately grounding the max
9 and said Regulators would make sure
the planes were safe before they fly
again that potential loss of Faith could
impact the range of planes that Boeing
is able to offer in years to come and to
understand why you need to go back to
the max crashes of 2018 and 2019 an
Indonesia passenger plane crashing into
the sea minutes after takeoff Rescuers
have located debris but they do not
expect to find any survivors the new
Boeing 737 crashing just minutes after
takeoff in Ethiopia 157 people people
from more than 30 countries were killed
the crashes of two Boeing 737 Max 8
aircraft led to the grounding of
hundreds of jets for nearly 2 years the
FAA began increasing its oversight of
Boeing's manufacturing and the company
had to pay billions to compensate
Airlines due to the max grounding and
problems that emerged with other
aircraft it slowed everything down uh it
took up resources it took up time and so
Boeing arguably wasn't able to focus on
developing the next new a colcraft in a
way they could have been fast forward to
2023 EMB boing now has a far narrower
selection of planes than European rival
Airbus who's offering ranges from the
100 seat a220 all the way up to the
massive a 351,000 Airbus also has the
a321 Neo which can fly a greater number
of passengers farther than Boeing 737
Max 10 a plane which still isn't
certified because of delays related to
the max crisis and that's partly why
Airbus who overtook Boeing as the
world's largest playmaker in 2019 was
able to post record orders in 2023 far
outstripping Boeing's orders and there's
a question here does this difference
between the orders speak to maybe the
fact that Boeing's management are
distracted you know they're focused on
other things where Airbus is able to go
out there and just focused on winning
orders and you know working with
customers and being able to deliver a
more nuanced product lineup uh that can
really take away some of the market
share that Boeing has so even though the
plane landed safely could the Alaska
Airlines incident disrupts the duopoly
between Boeing and Airbus in the long
run well both Airbus and Boeing have
huge manufacturing backlogs so Airbus is
unlikely to gain much of an advantage in
the short term they're pretty much sold
out for the next you know 8 nine years
if you want to buy a big chunk of new
orders from Airbus you're really looking
at the early 2030s before Aus can even
start delivering them and handling the
max crisis may have made Boeing better
at dealing with its current woses we're
seeing the company are start to do
things differently they've said that
they will open uh their factories up to
Airlines if if the airlines want to send
um send crews in to inspect the process
but how Boeing goes about restoring
faith in its products and its
manufacturing over the next few months
could dramatically reshape the company
in the years to come if they're able to
come back very strongly confident in the
fixes show that they have you know not
only addressed the underlying issues but
manag to win back the confidence of the
global industry maybe this is just a
blip but if there's a lack of faith in
the company and its products we could
see Boeing's orders and its position in
the market start to slip further in the
long
run